So how did you check that your code worked?
Hopefully, you did check that the conference keys to
attend contains conference key string. And you shouldn't have
found the conference keys to attend contained conference name, because
it doesn't. So another good thing to check is
that after you register for a conference, the seats available
goes down by one. So the first time you
register the seats available, it's going to down by one less
than the max attendees. Of course, if you log out
and log in as a different user and then register
for the same conference again, seats available is going to go
down by even more than one less the max attendees.
And yes, in our application you can register for a
conference you created. Okay. So let's take a quick look
at the finished code for register for conference. And we're
in the conference API class here. You already know if
the user's null through an unauthorized exception. Here
we start the transaction ofy.transact and then here, we
do the public wrapped Boolean run, wrapped Boolean
is what we're going to return. We get the
conference key. We just load the conference from
the datastore, should be familiar with doing that by
now. If there's no conference found, take the appropriate
action. Get the user's profile from the data store.
Check the various conditions before we allow the user
to register, and if all looks good, go ahead
and book the seat. So we add the conference
key to the conference keys to attend property of
the profile, we book the seat on the conference.
And then, very importantly, we save the profile and
the conference and we return the wrapped Boolean. Now,
if we didn't get a success throw the exceptions.
We already talked about that.